the one that i always think about that
got away
was called go like hell uh which
eventually did get made is ford versus
ferrari
[Music]
i uh i always wanted to make a racing
film
and um the thing about racing movies is
it can't be about
racing it has to have some amazing story
underneath
uh to to warn itself being made
and um that story was one of those
great uh stories of an incredible
friendship
and an incredible rivalry and an
incredible
you know incredibly dangerous race um
so uh we um i wouldn't say we got close
to production but
i got to the point where i had uh
tom cruise and brad pitt at a table read
reading the script together
which was pretty nice um but
uh we couldn't get the budget to to the
number it had to be at
um and it was the right number um
but uh so that was the one
for me that got away but i was thrilled
to see that
they ended up making an amazing version
of it um so
uh but yeah that would be my story how
close was the vision
of the version that you had to what uh
mangle brought to screen with ford v
ferrari
the script was the same um and i think
his approach
was generally how i was gonna do it
which was real cars
real racing obviously making it with
tom uh that's
you know that's the only way that it
would be made is if we were strapping
you know in some ways it was the top gun
what we did for top gun we were going to
do for car racing with mounted cameras
and all that um
so uh uh i thought he did an
excellent version and i thought
christian bale and matt damon
you know nailed the characters so that
was a case where like you go in going
god i hope this is good because i love
the story
so much and um i actually saw it with
tom we were both thrilled
uh when we saw it so that was that was
that's kind of a weird it's a weird
thing to see
someone make a movie of something that
you had kind of
got close to making but but
they did an amazing job with it